searching for a job during the pandemic
it is a daunting task and this morning
we're looking at how coronavirus
is changing the hiring process there's a
lot more zoom interviews involved of
course perhaps you've been dealing with
that yourself
hector mejia live this morning in
henderson with some insight from
industry experts how to find that job
hector
yeah and it feels like there's a ton of
zoom interviews involved nowadays
this morning we're at a chemical
manufacturing company here in henderson
they have job opportunities and earlier
at the top of the hour we were talking
with a recruiter about ways to stand out
and now
we're going to talk about the job
opportunities here joining us live
we have royal marty ceo here at
substrata to talk to us
first of all what is happening here
anderson good morning good morning good
morning
yeah so we are a biochemical
manufacturing company we manufacture
chemicals that are used
for road construction all the way to
cleaning and our biggest product is
called permazine and as you can see it
hardens the soil to a concrete-like
surface that's used for rural roads
and you bring that up because this is
part of the hiring process so tell us
how the pandemic is changing how you
guys are
a reaching out to people and b choosing
who you guys are going to hire
yeah so fortunately through the pandemic
we've grown quite a bit
but that's also made hiring a very
challenging thing for us so what we do
is first thing we ask for a video from
the applicant so we want to know a
little bit about you
and then the next step is we send you
this demo kit
and you right here and you complete the
demo kit
and then you go through that process and
then you formulate a pitch
or an idea of how to further the
products for us
and it's really important that you bring
up the video because you know we were
talking yesterday and you were telling
me that very few people actually
submit that video so if you're looking
for a job and you're told to submit a
video
go ahead and submit the video yes i
would say about uh 10
of the people actually submit a video
for us so what does this do this is like
really hard the product the premise time
yeah so
it's a it's an enzyme-based product and
so the enzyme
runs through and plays matchmaker with
the soil and permanently bonds those
soil particles together
and this product this surface will last
10 to 15 years
with little to no maintenance and it's
all made here in henderson all made here
in henderson
lastly you guys are hiring right now
correct we are hiring uh
marketing digital marketing people sales
people and warehouse assistants
all right thank you very much we're
running out of time but we'll be back at
six o'clock with more information we're
also going to talk with a recruiter
at the top of the hour for now reporting
live hector mejia back to you guys